you said something very kind to me and I
don't know if you want me to say it on
the air maybe you don't and you can take
it out but it really meant a lot to me
you said you know I never worry about
you that's true that was such a
wonderful thing to hear it's like sort
of like took took me a bat I was like
really yeah I really loved hearing that
well I I meant it and then I actually
referenced in the beginning of the
episode your career Arc but I first met
you as a stand-up right you're doing
stand-up comedy and you were so funny
and your material was so sharp and well
observed and obviously stand up see to
write your own material you have to have
the fortitude to get up there and
deliver it and so I met you in that guys
then I saw you uh as I said in one of my
favorite shows of all time in Silicon
Valley and and I thought
I love this guy I love the show I
thought everyone was perfectly cast yeah
and um that is a very hard thing to pull
off it's you know uh in so many ways the
perfect show and my son and I have
really bonded over that show we love
that show and re-watch it a lot and then
uh you made the big sick and I just like
I I you know you and your wife made it
and I was just seeing like oh this guy
just keeps leveling up which I thought
was very impressive and then you've had
this whole other Arc oh thank you so I'm
I'm I I don't worry about you do you
worry about Conan at all and you can be
honest no I don't worry about Conan you
know what's what's what's
interestingly insane yeah but because I
don't care
well that's another great way not so you
don't really and also to be fair you
don't really worry about anyone yeah no
I worry about I could count the people
on my hands on a good day my mother uh
brother I really worry about uh Emily
um no I I what's been inspiring about
your career is you've done so many
things too and you've been so good at
finding a sort of
um of evolving yourself and you know
doing these like long-form interviews
which at the beginning
you know I for obviously I watched The
Simpsons but it was your show on NBC
then when I first started watching and
you were doing like comedy that I had
never seen on TV before I'd never seen
that kind of Comedy it was like
surreal and risky and bizarre and it was
awesome and to see how since then all
the stuff you've done now
um sort of redefining yourself over and
over it's really really inspiring
continuing to be very funny and
insightful and relevant oh that's so
nice I I it is interesting that
um there was a quote I read a long time
ago
um by I can't remember who it was it
might have been like Eric Clapton or
someone but it was way back in the late
70s and
um he some band met him or some famous
musicians met him and they're like oh my
God you know Eric Clapton and he just
said to them uh what's your advice and
he just said Keep moving yeah keep
moving and and I I it kind of rang a
bell with me a little bit which is uh
I'm in I am now Eric Clapton in any
reality uh but I do believe it struck me
that he wasn't
sitting back and saying huh yeah I'm
Eric Clapton and what I've noticed over
the years and I see this a lot with
musicians and comedians is there the
ones that I tend to admire
don't
they never settle down and go you know
what I did it
I did it they just don't do it and
that's the yin and the Yang of it it's
very uh it's It's Tricky but they you
know the Martin shorts the Steve
Martin's all these people that I really
admire from a generation or two before
mine
um they
they're restless and they're constantly
trying to find that uh next way that
they can explore whatever it is they
have whatever their talent is they can
explore it and and Define it and uh that
intrigues me that really fascinates me
when people can do that yeah and to see
Steve Martin and Martin Short at this
point of their careers doing the best
work of their careers like I truly think
they've never been better and they make
it look so effortless which is part of
the appeal I think of that show is
you know they make you feel safe you're
like oh I'm in the hands of pros and uh
the way Martin Short is sort of you know
doing the Martin Short thing but but in
a way that's uh like Works within that
reality right it's so good the other
side of that though is it's something
I've been working on and I talked to
Emily about a lot she says you don't
ever take a moment to be like happy for
anything you've done
uh she says she calls it rest on your
laurels she's like you should every now
and then do that but
um I think to a fault for me I don't
have it like I just finished shooting
Chippendales in July it's the toughest
shoot of my life it was very very
exhausting very very satisfying and
wonderful and magical five months
and she was like as soon as it's done
you're gonna start freaking about what
you're gonna do next and I was like no
I'm so proud of this show and my work in
it and everybody else is working it that
this time I won't have that this time I
won't think that this was the last job
of my career and that now it's done and
then I took a week I slept for a week
and then on Monday I was like this is it
that's the end of my career nothing else
is coming what's next
so it does lead to uh anxiety I mean you
know I've chosen a life we all have
although this gives you some stability
well you don't have stability you it's
always like thing to thing to thing it
feels like you're always jumping onto
the next Lily Pad you know
um and so I would like to have a little
bit more of a
um comfort in like looking at the whole
career rather than just thinking job to
job to job I think it's tough too
because you are still young I always
think maybe this comes later on
um I'm no spring chicken and I keep I'm
I sometimes get the first hints of it
now of just someone will show me
something from our show in 93 and I'm so
young and I don't even remember I have I
have no
um
I don't know I don't really have much of
a connection to it anymore I feel like
I'm not even I'm not even that person
it's a different person because it was
so long ago and they say every cell in
your body has been fully replaced after
seven years that yeah this is now 30
years ago that's four conants ago yeah
exactly it's Fork
exactly four cones ago and um they're
not improving either
it's a copy of a copy of a copy of a
copy but uh I will look at it and I'll
feel an affection for that guy because I
know
well he's well intentioned and I know
how hard he's working and he's really
putting this stuff out there and he's
getting screamed at by the network that
night and but he's ah God love him I
hope his skin clears up